hello everybody my name is Margo barn
welcome to Sally dot exe now a long time
ago and this was so long ago that I
could be considered a little itty-bitty
baboo at this point I played a game
called sonic.exe and people loved it
like people went nuts over it or maybe
they didn't love it because it was a
little bit weird and disturbing based
off of this creepy pasta but this is
Sally dot exe a game made by the same
person that made the original sonic dot
exe I knew about it but I haven't played
it yet because oh my gosh I don't know
Kyle didn't want to play with me what a
shame I'm not Kyle I'm mark I would
gladly play with you but I can play with
you right Ross my name is Don Rock
Ross just left I saw that don't think
you can fool me I'm too sharp for you
I've had years of experience to come
back to you not perfect
act 1 oh look it's a romantic venture
between Amy and Sonic and there's a
giant orbiting donut slash butthole
possibly Sonic don't know no Sonic no no
that's how this all started
uh already then okay I'm so in love I
think I just exploded Oh
oh yay oh no baby na ho ho she turned
into a Frankenstein monster all stitched
together what in Sonic do to you and who
the hell is that I'm playing us on a
game in a long time I don't remember who
that is uh let's go for it let's see
what horrible fate but Falls that person
kind and fair oh I bet oh I bet I bet oh
it's beautiful is that the Magic Kingdom
of Sonic land behind you or something
equally is disturbing as Disney bullying
ah I don't remember a bunny character
well a picking up speed now Wow
it's like they actually ripped the sonic
engine out of the old ah
you're having so much fun
oh no oh that's Sally I know Sally
jeepers the name of the game why why is
this happening
sonic why why are you doing this to
these lovable characters blank act 9
when did we jump from act Oh Sonic hey
how's it going Sonic how you doing can I
move I can't see it oh my god it's
disturbing everyone's around me just
staring away Oh God
Oh the walls are closing in no Sonic no
all those things I said about yeah I
didn't mean it ah you always knew Amy
wasn't good enough for you I'm me Sally
a what I mean a mark I'm not really
Sally but I guess I'll pretend to be for
now if it means you don't squish me
today I'm gonna die or Sally's going to
huh boy ah
I remember that I remember that what
game over
I just got started you can't do what
what doesn't make it acceptance we
didn't the other was the other one
that's short I don't remember it's been
so long I should have watched my old
playthrough sonic dot exe before I came
here what the hell happened
Oh No hang on wait there anything else
that I can be done hello that the end
not really it are you just playing a
trick on me a Trixie chick come on I
guess that might be it actually and let
me see some I guess that's it I can't
find anything else to do if I do I'll
add it on later but for now I think
that's the end god that was such a short
experience years build up to this I mean
it was creepy but it wanted more have
wanted more but either way that was
Sally dot exe if you want to see little
itty bitty markiplier like just a baby
about three years ago I played this
sonic dot exe game and if you want to
see it and see how yeah strange I was
back then just too strange I am now but
it's in a different way
check out the annotation over there and
the link in the description below thanks
again everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
all hail metal well I mean metal um very
useful there's various different types
of metals led1 north oh god that's right
they just turned horrible
this isn't you I mean I wasn't told that
you were gonna be here your big freaking
simply knows
Oh